these Brewery incentives have definitely
sparked interest and has brought many
breweries to the city of Las Vegas I
have
thankfully a plethora of them in ward 3
in the arts district and we already know
that there are already some interest in
the new incentives that we're offering
for the second phase of attracting and
really virgining the brewery row Concept
in the arts district so we're looking
forward to that continued investment in
our community and making those dreams
possible of those folks who want to
bring a brewery to our city finally we
have the Las Vegas breweries supplying
beer to
all the new restaurants here and you can
have a locally made beer finally and
that's what people are ordering when
they go out of town is they they ask for
the local beer so no matter what town or
or state you go to people now finally
want to
both of you the relationship between the
brewery row and the arts district is
very very symbiotic and helpful I think
it's part of the Greater Community to
make these Brews it's an art of itself
you have to kind of know and Tinker with
what kinds of flavors and um just uh
experiences you want to share with the
folks who are sampling your Brews but I
think that it goes hand in glove with
all the other offerings there in the
immediate adjacency we have different
eateries we have the roller skating we
have the Arts galleries that people can
go after they've had a few brews and and
enjoy all of the other offerings in
terms of retail and going to look at the
Vintage shops and finding that one thing
that you're out on the lookout for and
that you know that only this special
place makes you find it
[Music]
oh